[Музика]
закоханий в Китай один, мабуть, не так багато,
що це поки не дасть вам водну камеру,
щоб вони дозволили просто розповісти нам, мій мій
робот, отриманий загальний шуйський чхання
Роза Мілла, як з Ашокою, це моє шоу
в морських водоростях, також покажіть побожних  Лінея
Навуходоносор на твоїй палці подвійний
дек найбільше вона гуляла
можливостями для вічності знімків на
K - ось - Сабіна гонки субсидії
відновлено це Панетта
привіт усім пора
уроку англійської мене звати Наталія лешка
давайте почнемо і я хотів би  привітати
мого дуже дорогого гостя сьогодні привіт Сідней
привіт як справи сьогодні я добре дякую
добре, тому ми продовжуємо говорити про
подорожі це урок номер вісім, тож
давайте спочатку почнемо, давайте перевіримо
домашнє завдання, яке виконують наші студенти, тому я
попросив вас  напишіть список речей, які вам
потрібні для вашої сімейної подорожі, тож давайте поговоримо
з Сергієм, чи подобається вам подорожувати з
родиною так, так, добре, тому уявіть, що ви
пакуєте свій сімейний валізу, що ви
збираєтеся?  o покладіть туди те, що ви збираєтеся
бути предметами О закривається добре черевики гарне
здоров'я хороші сонцезахисні окуляри, так що все
добре зроблено Зарядні пристрої гарний телефон хороший ноутбук
ідеальний
гм книги тільки один добре що ще нам потрібно ще
два предмети ще два ще що щодо
паспортних документів  ви можете просто подякувати
вам документи, так, будь-які особисті
речі, наприклад, без повідомлень.
важливо паспорт
це як паспорти телефон гроші
кредитні картки і так далі припустимо добре,
давайте уявімо, що вам дозволено
взяти лише п'ять речей з десяти, що
буде, тому не потрібно взуття, сонцезахисні окуляри або
те, що ви збираєтеся виключити найближче
добре  телефон гарні документи ну тоді
кредитні картки добре черевики і ще
одне та зарядний пристрій О, Борисе добре,
так що пройдіть список і виберіть
найважливіші пункти, це
питання пріоритетності w  якщо у вас є список з
десяти, а потім ви збираєтеся обмежити його
п'ятьма три двома або одним, у цьому випадку ви
збираєтеся уникати речей, які вам
більше не потрібні. Ні,
але якщо вони скажуть, я буду спілкуватися  з
Мадонною з Елізіуму
добре, давайте рухатися далі, тому ми продовжуємо
говорити про транспорт, подивіться
на слова, можете ви вгадати слова, можливо,
деякі з них я не впевнений, що о, добре,
всі голосні вони зникають це hosni
буквально бачить мою претензію добре можна  Ви
вгадуєте слова, наприклад, це
легкий
Jib GPS, і він знає, що ви бачите,
відстежуєте хорошу колію поїзда, колію, трек,
це дорога, але якщо ми говоримо про
транспортні засоби, вантажівка, вантажівка, так,
це вантажівка, добре, поїзд, хороший підводний човен, хороший
вертоліт  добре, що з цього,
який цей, так G з G ви можете
знайти це у Венеції в Італії гумовий долар
йдіть на землю на скелі
повторюйте за мною йдіть на землю або
молодець, і ви перетворите гондолу ідеально, що
щодо цього скутера  добре, що
цей складається  з двох працівників
так, дякую, що це справді автобус, добре
зроблений двоповерховий добре виконаний мотоцикл
я думаю, що твій
улюблений мотоцикл
так, так, а що щодо цього одного тренера так, це не бос,
цей автобус, тож давайте перевіримо слова
правильно, я думаю  так, хто розуміє
слова, будьте обережні зі словом вантажівка, ми
маємо вас там, а не в цьому випадку, якщо у вас
є буква а, це будуть
інші слова, тож тепер для вас є завдання,
приготуйтеся взяти аркуш
паперу або  зошит і ми будемо
писати диктант буде диктантів
чи не так Сергій я готовий я буду
диктувати слова ви запишіть добре
а ви хлопці ви пишіть з нами а
потім перевіримо так давайте  номер один
буде гондола, номер два
буде мотоциклом і тут також пишуть
добре, номер три буде
підводним човном
номер три буде тролейбусом BOTS
двоповерховий
номер шість - скутер номер сім -
вертоліт
і останній  один буде тренером
добре ми закінчимо тут все добре зачекайте
вертоліт ой зачекайте зачекайте
так хлопці ви перевірте свої слова і Сергій
перевірте з нами тут я зробив три
помилки навмисне знайдіть помилки так три
помилки навмисне що ви вважаєте
правильним гондола правильна
гондоля  правильно молодець
мотоцикл правильно правильно браво
тролейбус тролейбус про Декер
добре добре добре ось і все, так що
номер три не правильний вертоліт
і тренер не правильний ви згодні, тож
давайте виправимо помилки то що, на
вашу думку, не так  підводний човен, ми
повинні змінити вас на краще, тому тут ми
повинні написати вам і тут підводний човен у
вас є те саме, так, ідеально,
а тепер давайте з гелікоптером він і
я так, ми повинні змінити II і я
молодець і тренер світу, гей, а не
ви так правильно,
зараз давайте перевіримо ще раз Браво
чудово, молодець, тож давайте далі, а
тепер є нове завдання для вас, слухайте
уважно, нам потрібно вирішити проблему
добре, так що голландці у нас є сім'я
назва сімей посмішки це
їх ім'я прізвище у нас чотири
члени чи можемо ми назвати числа мама
тато дочка і син чотири людини
вони досить багаті, тому вони можуть
багато думати про своє життя і
є зворотній зв'язок  з дітей, що вони не
люблять довго подорожувати, вони ненавидять
подорожувати по 10 годин 15 годин, тому
ще раз посміхається для членів досить багатих
і вони не люблять подорожувати надовго,
давайте подивимося на цю картинку,
тому  хто вони сім'я, я так не думаю,
так що вони друзі, і у нас є
скільки членів три,
як ви думаєте, вони багаті чи не дуже
багаті вони не дуже багаті, як ви бачите,
тому у нас є лише одна ознака, щоб вони не  у
мене багато грошей, мало грошей, і
вони люблять разом веселитися, співаючи
танці тощо, отже, у нас є номери
три, тож варіант номер три: ви чуєте, у
мене є пан.  Сергію, так ти сам
пишеш Mr.  сер, він так один учасник, я думаю, що
він не дуже багатий і він не бідний,
просто середня людина погоджуюсь, Сергій,
достатньо, достатньо,
середній, і він дуже зайнятий, він не може
дозволити собі подорожі на великі відстані або це
має бути дуже швидко  ви прямо тут ваш
критерій, так що давайте, у нас є
сім'я посмішки Франції і пан.  Сергій і
завдання всі ці люди хочуть поїхати
до Португалії вибрати найкращий
транспорт для них скажи ти
сам думаєш а Сергій мені тут допоможе
посміхається їхні друзі і Сергій
що їм краще подорожувати на
мотоциклі чи на  автомобіль на таксі на
підводному човні на гелікоптері оберіть найкращий
предмет Сергій давайте, що ви думаєте
, що підійде для цих
людей ми їдемо з Кіта так Френк
ти до Португалії так що для сім'ї найкраще
означає, я думаю, це літак, якщо я зроблю
літак добре для друзів, мабуть, поїзд
добре, а для мене також хліб літак літак
добре ви б хотіли поїхати, але самі
на гелікоптері чому б ні, але це занадто далеко
для Києва для вечірок
добре скільки часу вам потрібно на дорогу
з Києва до Португалії  що
добре, якщо ви їдете на вертольоті
на літаку
скільки землі це щось приблизно три
години три години, можливо, чотири години правильно,
це добре, стримери три години нормально
для гри, але гелікоптер їде
бути швидшим або повільнішим трохи повільніше
повільніше один C, тож, ймовірно,
що щодо ціни, якщо ми подорожуємо
літаком, буде дорожче,
ніж дорогий гелікоптер, але це
залежить від того, чи це приватний літак, тому ми
обговорюємо це на  наші уроки, тому літак,
ймовірно, дешевший вертоліт, якщо це
приватний вертоліт, може бути дорожчим, так
само, як і їхній літак, який є
приватним, він буде
дорожчим,
давайте з Францією, про яку ви згадували,
що вони можуть подорожувати поїздом, так,
вони"  ти думаєш, що це
буде цікаво для них,
це побачить вас тільки тому, що ви можете
бачити, як я танцюю так, ці друзі
абсолютно праві, так що це буде
насправді автобус, також може бути так,
автобус може бути можливим  а також тому, що
це буде довше і дуже дешево,
тож якщо ви думаєте, що потяг чи автобус,
що буде дешевше для друзів,
то віддайте Португалії, я думаю, що
поїзд буде дешевшим так, так, добре, якщо
цей реж.  ectory це буде дешевше,
безумовно, військовий автобус
так, я особисто, якщо ви запитаєте мене
особисто, я б пішов на автобус,
тому що я можу робити зупинки в різних
країнах, фотографувати, розважатися, спробувати
місцеву їжу, я поїду на автобусі, але це
займе більше часу, так  Звичайно, це
буде довше, а для вас
ви згадали літак чи вертоліт,
штани, дуже дякую, хлопці, давайте
рухатися далі, тепер настав час для бабусі, і моє
типове запитання: «Ні, як бабуся, ні, чому
всі ненавидять бабусю, це дуже легко,
добре і  ми любимо бабусю, тому сьогодні ми
продовжуємо говорити про теперішній досконалий
час, тому ми говоримо про досвід або
дії, які сталися в минулому та
невизначений час, тож давайте переглянемо
стверджувальні запитання позитивні запитання
стратегія в одному напрямку що ми використовуємо
тут ви з'їли вона так
співає  їли і сьогодні, наприклад, маємо
Brava якщо ми ставимо запитання
питальні питання питальні
речення
або питання тут шеф-кухар ти їв
так він або вона є він або  вона і важкий
Брахма, і відповідь буде так,
я так, добре чи ні, я не
драба,
і якщо ми говоримо про неї, так, вона є,
і ні, у неї немає
Браво і негативне запитання, як ви
згадували, ми використовуємо поточний  або hasn't
amazing Я впевнений, що у вас однакові
відповіді, тому давайте трохи потренуємося. Для
вас є завдання, щоб ви використовували дієслова
зі списку в теперішньому досконалому заперечному,
щоб закінчити речення, тому, як
приклад, Марія не була  в Іспанію, тож вона
хоче поїхати туди цього літа, а ти їдеш
з нами,
номер два, подивіться на речення,
а Сергій, ви даєте мені відповідь, вона
мм-хм,
яку частину Іспанії вона хоче відвідати,
хоча йди забронюй, перебуваючи всередині, щоб вона
ще не визначила вікову частину Іспанії, яку вона
хоче відвідати, так, молодці, вона
ще не вирішила, яку частину Іспанії вона
хоче відвідати, але коли я бачу
дуже урочистий номер три, тому вона
ще не забронювала квитки  вона не
забронювала або вона не забронювала чек не
добре купила, тому що  так, у нас є так
минулий причастий і номер чотири твої
друзі Алісія будь-які плани, щоб вона могла піти
з нею, не створила жодних планів,
тому вона моя, твоє ліки так і номер
п'ять вони хороші друзі, але
вони не пішли я маю на увазі  так, пішли пішли
пішли, це друга форма, це було просто,
і ми маємо першу так, так,
перш за все, і, звичайно,
вони не були на святах, ми можемо сказати, що
ми йдемо
добре, насправді ми можемо, але якщо ви подивитеся, так
ідіть  ми не використовуємо нижче, правильно,
ми вирішили забронювати мою PIN-код, тому будьте
обережні, іноді у вас є слова,
які вам не потрібно використовувати, ладно,
якщо ми думаємо про речення номер три
, тому вона не забронювала квитки, які у
неї немає  я не забронював квитки, чи не можете ви
поставити питання про це речення,
будь ласка, чи не вона освистала, так це можливо,
або якщо ви поставите позитивне запитання, яке ви
хочете поставити, чи вона
о, підручники з історії так, чи вона добре забронювала
квитки, і ви йдете
інтонація гасне, вона стукнула
квиток - ха  вона купила квитки
Браво, і давайте подивимося на останній, який
вони були у відпустці, чи можете ви поставити
запитання про якість як
B Браво добре, зараз давайте пограємо в гру,
чи подобається вам більше-менш
більше-менш  залежить від гри, так,
ви збираєтеся грати зі мною, тому
що нас тут лише двоє, і ви
можете грати з нами, або ви граєте зі своїми
друзями, членом сім'ї, тому подивіться на
картинку, як називається гра,
не знаю  убий трохи так, ми говоримо
нотатки та перехрещуємо нотатки через це що
хрестики-нолики,
так що подивіться, так що це наше поле,
і тут у нас є позитивне речення,
негативне речення або питання, і ось
давайте з нею, що буде
ось допоможіть мені, але йди, вимовляй привіт, я
добре, давайте
ND, і вони все зробили ідеально, тому ми
використовуємо Present Perfect Continuous
, щоб поставити вашу примітку або хрестик тут,
наприклад, вам потрібно сказати негативне
запитання, наприклад, I have'  Я не
був у Лондоні або ви можете дати мені
приклад негативний з i- quiz i
я не читав книгу так я не
читав книгу звичайно так я не читав
книгу, то що б ви хотіли вибрати,
що б ви хотіли бути вузлом або
хрестом-хрестиком
тому хрести завжди починаються, тож ти починаєш,
дайте мені речення, вона не була на
прямому Браво,
так що твій хрест тут, тепер моя черга,
і ти підеш зі мною, я піду сюди
посередині, тому я не був в Австралії
також твоя черга
[Музика]
так, має бути цікаво
Браво хм, це цікаво,
чесно кажучи.
забронював
квитки добре, молодець,
тепер моя черга
[Музика]
я з'їв суші, це хлопець пішов
запитати собі, наче ти не
пам'ятаєш, чи я їв суші добре,
це не так, це добре, ви повинні спробувати,
це прийшло, тому я  Я піду з
питанням джентльмен за джентльмена,
щоб вони забронювали квитки, а
Сергій для вас  ou they haven't rava and you
want to my вітання для вас так добре
зроблено, тому давайте переглянемо правильні та
неправильні дієслова, це дуже важливо
для учнів, тому червоний колір
буде неправильними дієсловами, які
неправильні дієслова ви пам'ятаєте мене,
ймовірно, це  love I want to Remember
like go go go gone so this is irregular
okay що ви пам'ятаєте зі
звичайними дієсловами like go what else
do do you memory the three form do
do D done is it correct y what else
CC so C Bravo
and it's  Миша, яка робить зроблено зробив Bravo
добре, зроби mate mate і давайте використовувати
регулярні з правильними дієсловами ми не
змінюємо його ми додаємо закінчення IDI like
play plays gray okay просто дай відтворити Luke
Luke Luke круто добре о, це гарна
комбінація lookbook whoo and play  тому
подивіться, я маю на
Маркуса червоний і зелений, я
вказую на вас і даю вам займенник,
наприклад, at she/he or they, а ви
даєте мені повне речення, використовуючи
теперішній досконалий час, який ви робите з нами,
наприклад, so red  я  скажи вона і ви
створіть речення о, вона зробила
домашнє завдання вона ні, у
неї немає успіху, вона не виконала
домашнє завдання правильно так правильно,
якщо я скажу, що вони не читали книгу
добре Я не пішов до  робота добре
вона не бачила кількох вона не бачила
іншого вона не бачила добре добре
ми не забронювали квитки добре я не
подивився на відео добре і тепер
ваша черга ми наприклад ми грали
ця гра і вона поїхала в
Італію молодці і ще один я
приготував вечерю і я забронював
квиток гарно дякую,
Сергій, давайте переглянемо неправильні дієслова
разом з нашими студентами ми вже
практикуємо неправильні дієслова гімнастику
любиш спорт так, який твій улюблений
ммм гонки.
все,
який чудовий чоловік, дуже дякую,
тож давайте з неправильними
дієсловами подивіться this is going to be
infinitive руки вгору закінчуються в
інфінітиві перша форма це друга
і пошук, наприклад go let's go
gone gone when I'm  пішов
так, так що робота йти має три різні чотири
іді пішов Бог Брахма
давайте йти це робити легко робити Баба
давайте йти ми побачимо так Браво давайте підемо
зі світовим скороченням сафарі пам'ятайте скорочення
скорочення скорочення це буде те саме скорочення
скорочення скорочення тому що форми так давайте
подивіться, дозвольте мені записати це для вас, тому виріжте
це інфінітив перша форма,
другий вирізайте, як подивіться на це
те саме, а другий такий самий
, тому ми робимо дії з тим самим
скороченням cut cut з  нам карти картки картки
Сергій кишки кишки кишки так
наприклад світ пут поут пут так
давайте зі словами прийди
гра
derstood
так правильно, і давайте розберемося зі словом
parva, яке, однак, має головки так
так, і слово play lay lay
laid не пам'ятає, це
грає правильні дієслова так, так що це
неправильні дієслова гімнастика, але не робіть
цього, це добре, це  жарт так швидко
прямо там правильні дієслова down let's go
з дієсловом go do C зробити половину та давайте
перевіримо їх добре go still get help me
будь ласка, молодець
, у вас є те саме go do leave and
don't
see soen soen perfect make made  гарно
виконано,
давайте додамо більше слів, щоб вони були добре
влучені добре читати подивіться, це
цікаве дієслово mm-hmm, тому що якщо ви
виконуєте неправильне дієслово gymnastic, ви
повинні робити це читати, читати, читати, але оскільки у
нас така сама форма читати читати читати  Я
маю на увазі, що ми пишемо так само, але ми
вимовляємо це посилання читати читати читати
щури щури, якщо хочете, ви можете зробити це читати,
читати, читати, просто щоб ви пам'ятали,
що вимова відрізняється. Добре,
останнє завдання для вас, чи можете ви навести мені
приклад просто  повторно  лещата з нею з побачити
її і побачити, що вона не бачила фільм, який
вона не бачила, добре, давайте зробимо це
знову  якщо у вас
є слово, наприклад, чи вона
снідала, окей, повторіть,
вона поснідала фантастично, і
давайте з нею і читаємо, вона не читала,
виглядає, і ще раз вона не
читала книгу і ще раз  вона не
читала книжку фантастично,
я впевнений, що це ти, ми згадали, що вона
взагалі не читала книгу
, він її не читав і швидше
вона кузина готова і швидше вона не
написала і швидше вона не написала
вона  ще не написав книгу,
тому ваше домашнє завдання наступного разу
давайте поглянемо, у вас є текст, це
з блогу, ви читаєте блог, і ви
знайшли тут п’ять помилок, тому прочитайте країну блогу
та знайдіть тут п’ять помилок
наступного разу, коли ми  збираються перевірити це,
і вони чують дзвінок, тому ми
повинні припинити урок  дуже дякую за те, що послухали,
вам сподобалось добре, так який спосіб
пересування ви пам'ятаєте о поїзд літак
вертоліт який психосамокат
тролейбус про це Керол я впевнений,
що ви пам'ятаєте більше, ніж Сергій, наступного
разу ми перевіримо  разом
побачимося завтра хто такий Вішну мужній крик
чи є в його резюме духи piccoli
ви знаєте, показує драматичний клас о, ви бажаєте
номінально коротше кажучи, весь клас третій
касиб рухається спостерігайте за мобільним, щоб робити
заняття не тоді, коли я закінчив клацання,
ніби зверху  paraquad вії
кодек України повинен хтось дати нам Каппа
призначення або який-небудь напад аборти
завжди і завжди і як практика
оренда вам не був випадок
візуалізація підкорює проспати пан.
pimiento Vashti Slovan Liberec Росія
Ізраїль Італія
[Музика]
ви